la central nuclear de sapo l'illa se
encuentra al otro lado del río dniéper
en la ciudad de mico por las fuerzas
rusas ocuparon el lugar en marzo y
últimamente han estado bombardeando
desde esa dirección la orilla norte
controlada por los ucranianos y
disparan todos los días todas las noches
desde enero dar donde está la central
nuclear y las fuerzas ucranianas no
podrían disparar en contra si le dan a
la planta la presión extenso es duro
duro duro dormimos muy mal por la noche
la agencia de energía nuclear de ucrania
dice que los rusos han colocado
recientemente al menos 14 piezas de
equipo militar pesado dentro de uno de
los edificios del reactor
están haciendo todo lo posible para
atrincherarse allí y han conducido todos
sus vehículos hasta la parte trasera de
esta sala de turbinas y dice que también
han almacenado explosivos a todo el
mundo la cuestión es qué pasa si hay un
incendio no será posible apagar el fuego
porque estos camiones bloquean el acceso
de los bomberos
la situación es aún más preocupante
porque en enero hogar se producen
tiroteos regularmente la semana pasada
murieron en este lugar tres militares
rusos y 12 resultaron heridos según el
alcalde exiliado de la ciudad
no descarto que haya sido obra de las
fuerzas ucranianas pero también hay
peleas internas entre los ocupantes ya
que ajustan cuentas entre ellos y luego
las utilizan para justificar su
presencia allí dicen que aquí hay
actividad de la oposición partidista así
que debemos quedarnos y
rusia ha acusado a las fuerzas
ucranianas de arriesgarse a una
catástrofe nuclear con su supuesta
actividad militar cerca del
emplazamiento de enero dar los
funcionarios ucranianos dicen que son
muy conscientes de los peligros y que no
correrían tales riesgos pero que no
están tan seguros de los rusos